bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi
saltati surreal mont royal loro iale
come che si dice quel gioco dove c'erano
i polli grossi c'è un castello a
sinistra taglia mandiamole nel castello
quando vuoi rendono via si va alla
chiesa in faccia la porta del castello
aspettava però davanti perfetto c'è
altra gente deve raccogliere roba vi
lascio per la festa riprende l'altra con
la effe salti in avanti i controlli il
saldo docente dall'altra parte all'altra
difficile all
poi ci sono i giocatori a kampala
sbaglia se appena mai facili non ho
capito sta roba
ma chi sono sono di mestre capo una
testa 32 ora erano giocatori veri doppia
kill per i nostri amici incredibili
la seconda è meritatissima o c'è un mago
che si sta attaccando pensionato laddove
sono unici per classe
ecco la sorella detto ecco è qualcosa
che sono io dove sono io sta uscendo in
questo momento preso in mano non ha più
armatura di curve di carica è quando
andato andato uno andato ok arrivo
arrivo attenzione occhio io ho caricato
arriva su un po di mare do peso prese
polpo neanche l'altro cd ma non
comprendo l'assassino mamma mia se
rimasta 33 i nas mirate prendi un in
faccia con questa che fa toglie 800
macello
eccolo vedo che si sta già guardando
però ci ha già visti se si fa il
canestro con lascia con finita stephen
curry occhio c'è uno che il cellulare a
casa di destra a sinistra stanno
sparando in ora sta sparati di vista una
tra di loro
ok tema di un pollo potrebbe esserci
ancora una tv ora l'ultimo ce n'è ancora
una buona andato
no no no sicuramente c'è però qualcuno
occhio chiocchio c'è gente li fai te li
fai te di farli ma ripeto noi
eccomi una grande due spaccati esco baby
bene bene tensione che se ci siamo fatti
pareggiando dic il ceo 6 killed two 7
benvenuto della partita ecco le cose
davanti a noi dove 12 15 15 ma quanti ad
atene sia poi qualche prima ci sono rock
and roll ce l'ho ce l'ho preso non c'è
una presa diretta morto o platea di
quanti leggendari per te lo re anche
quasi anche se prendi le tue non li vedo
ecco io non vedo il costone orbo autore
mining qui qui sopra qui sopra sinistra
e il flash udine e sopra è sempre sopra
le sei tu che stanno attaccando
ok guerriere lo ok andamento guerriero
dietro di te
anche lui è andato perfetto e ci siamo
signori che la gallina da galati fi non
riesce a uccidere la gallina che i
problemi più difficile il signore la
gallina e mi fa sul serio si mi sono
sorpreso di me stesso stavolta allora
sei remaining tutti noi stiamo facendo
gli altri non si ammazzano tra di loro
solo noi ammazziamo gente sono tutti tua
lizzati occhio qui quattro fregate e
mangiati lorenzi sala maffei due contro
due e noi li abbiamo sentiti come ha
fatto i nostri amici o sento un mago ma
gueda est ecco lì dietro l'albero 75
occhio scontro finale ecco reso ho preso
il toto 700 a quello lo vedo preso ed è
sotto 8400 un boulevard è da tutti e due
polli buon mio amico bisogna uccidere
liquori uno li rendono neanche visti
abbiamo l'ambizione 310 rischi o
guardaci non lo lasciano un'ora ad
essere una dietro l'altra abbia vinto va
bene grazie tommy è stato proprio bello
non mi direbbe o questo è un gioco
porca vacca e non perché ho vinto serate
pre convinto se non mi farebbe cagare
però è veramente figo
tanto io non capisco se il mago è una
donna un uomo perché non riesco a
vederli in faccia è una donna
se ti giri velocissimo riesce a vedere
gli occhi mi viene una donna la valle
dei funghi e non e amsterdam ma si
chiama fungal forest tensione e gli
edifici sembrano un po voli di amsterdam
ebbene insegnano che se guardi bene vedi
anche amedeo preziosi in giro siccome se
schianto su un fungo che succede
l'ombra del fungo non c'è pro c'è la mia
va bene c'è gente ci sono precedenti di
sotto occhio sostenibile e no la spada e
mio marito stava marcando
domani se non ci fosse un domani c'è un
hp morto mago diventato un pollo ve lo
lascio a giustiziare non riesco neanche
a giustiziare aveva della che sono
rimaste le piume guarda no non lo vedo
io che bank sono rimaste le piume in
aria
va bene allora fai un file polemica oggi
sente quadro è da vedere maglia che è
male ma come è possibile ci hanno lane è
morto eva di quando hai a che vale poi
la buona tavola
anzi aspetto ha visto la musichetta per
i cavalli è la patron karate adattata
dal dan è stato il momento veramente i
tipi di passione di emozione grazie
sentito orca vasca hanno appena cra
stato diamogli a prendere subito
eh no io sono sulla forgia non censura
eccolo arrivò capello non esca mai
provato uscire dalla finestra ero troppo
grasso
ma sai che quello che da oggi sarà
prossimamente eh sì perché la vo colpito
un bot e pochissima no vabbè questa è
stata quindi che ce n'era un altro
danaro scemo io non ce la faccio
questo scetticismo per il warrior prende
uno tra via ci sta comunque ho fatto
schifo dell'atterraggio
io sono una montagna tipo sono in casa
secondo piano e dimmi quando allora
eccola dal tackle a livello si è visto
anche lui nel peso un guerriero un lato
1 ok 1 andato
ex chiatta pollo non è detto che la
guarda ma porca vacca 26 papa qua da me
pagamento sono invisi preso ok ora di
fare gli scemi medi che torna normale
grock fas la gente a 75 75 livello di
vado via
sono qua da me a 6 passano a pistolina
di tornate vero che la vera anche gli
ingegneri fa veramente pena st pistola o
uno è un po lo vivi vivi nel scatolone
morto tutt'e due morti viene congelato
c'è l'altro qua c'è un'altra carica
rivali per i vari buon sarà pari a
spostarmi fanno veramente schifo duro
porca vacca quanta gente da vieni su
vieni su un al mondo e dal monte dal
mondo della moda delle mante ne ha
colpito uno aia che vale la dietro da
ovunque sono posso credere mi dispiace
al vetro questo punto la vista si stando
dietro i tempi
ma la gente muore in questo gioco quale
che di visitatori atlete che sia
piaciuto sia cresciuto e sta venendo
incontro valore erano muore ortigia
ok bellissimo in 18ma edizione per una b
l'italia fa schifo è tranquillo scalando
la montagna è ciò che ti sparo chiama
sparata ai vedovi se v70 mondo ma mi ha
colpito ma mi hanno sparato
ti vedo non vedo sento al 100 giro largo
mi sa e non ne vorrei vorrei sbagliarmi
di parliamone spavento no no non riesco
a colpirlo ma poi mi sono un pollo li
puoi farli poi ce la puoi fare lo riesca
puoi fare sta sopravvivendo l'anno
entrambi gli wissing ok è vero nota fate
voi l'ho colpito non è morto non
uccidermi sbaglia sbaglia ma giusto con
l'abilità mi ha ucciso parma dove ai
ragazzi la vittoria è arrivata per
essere una partita cioè per essere una
delle prime partite sono super contento
poi mi piace botto ringrazio thomas col
solito l'accesso canal in descrizione se
vi dove è piaciuto se il tracciato mi
piace che la ricerca della giustizia
ci vediamo dai
[Musica]